returned from keeve
where we went at the request of
president biden and the invitation of
president zelinski
we had an opportunity to demonstrate
directly
our strong support our strong ongoing
support
for the ukrainian government
and for the ukrainian people
this was in our judgment an important
moment to be there
an important moment for for ukraine
for the war
an important moment to have
face-to-face conversations in detail
about the
[Music]
extraordinary
support that we've provided security
economic humanitarian
as well as the massive pressure that
we've been exerting on russia
and then to talk in detail about how we
carry that forward
across all of those fronts
i would say that
without putting words in his mouth
president zielenski
express a deep appreciation
for president biden's leadership and for
the incredible generosity and support of
the american people
uh in turn
we expressed
deep admiration
for his leadership for the extraordinary
courage
of ukrainians in standing up to
and pushing back this russian aggression
part of our commitment going forward
involves a number of things that i was
able to share with president zilensky
yesterday including the return of
american diplomats to ukraine starting
next week
including
president biden's attempt to nominate a
new ambassador to ukraine ambassador
bridget brink
an ambassador someone i've served with
for a long time deeply experienced in
the region he'll be a very strong
representative for the united states in
ukraine
we
had an opportunity as well to
talk about where this goes from here um
with the success that ukraine has had
it's also true that russia continues to
try to brutalize parts of the country
and the death and destruction uh that we
continue to see is horrific
but ukrainians are standing up they're
standing strong and they're doing that
with the support that we have
coordinated uh from literally around the
world
um
the strategy that we've uh put in place
massive support for ukraine
massive pressure against russia
uh solidarity uh with more than 30
countries uh engaged in these efforts
is having real results
and we're seeing that when it comes to
russia's war aims
russia is failing
ukraine is succeeding
russia has sought as its principal aim
to totally subjugate ukraine to take
away its sovereignty to take away its
independence
that has failed
it sought to assert the power of its
military
and its economy we of course are seeing
just the opposite a military that is
dramatically underperforming
an economy as a result of sanctions as a
result of a mass exodus from russia
that is in shambles
and it sought to divide the west and
nato
of course we're seeing exactly the
opposite an alliance more divided than
i've ever seen it and indeed
new countries
considering
applying for membership
the bottom line
is this
we don't know how the rest of this war
will unfold
but we do know
that a sovereign independent ukraine
will be around a lot longer than
vladimir putin's on the scene
and our support for ukraine going
forward
will continue it will continue until we
see final success during the meeting we
expressed our
deepest condolences to the president
for the loss of so many civilians and of
course
the loss of those uh courageous troops
that have done just a magnificent job
of pushing back uh russian forces
we also
expressed our admiration for their
professionalism and for their commitment
to defend their their democracy just
it's been extraordinary to watch and i
think everyone would agree with me there
i agree with secretary blinken that the
president did express
uh his
deep appreciation along with uh minister
of defense and the chief of defense
uh their deep appreciation for what the
american people
have continued to do
to ensure that we get them
as much assistance
as possible as quickly as possible
so
our focus in the meeting was to
talk about those things that would
enable us to win the current fight and
also build for tomorrow
and and uh again a very productive
discussion
we talked about security force
assistance
and we talked about training and we also
talked about
the
key things that we're going to discuss
in the session that i'll conduct
tomorrow at ramstein with a number of
ministers of defense and chiefs of
defense this session is focused on
doing things to generate
additional capability and capacity for
the ukrainian forces and so it's a great
opportunity uh to get a good update from
the child from the minister of defense
and from the president on the things
that they are focused on the things that
they need that will enable us to have a
more productive discussion with the
chads and ministers of defense tomorrow